[Music]
hello everyone
uh so we'll continue from where we left
off last time
we are going to apply this
particular statement for the balance of
linear momentum
to this tetrahedron figure but in order
to do
do that we'll use the mean value theorem
of
integration okay so let me go to a next
to the next page but i will
uh i've already copied this figure
just paste it here
and maybe also reduce the size of this
figure a little bit
okay think i'm happy with that
okay uh
so because i uh just just taking a brief
look at the previous slide
because i want to use this mean value
theorem for integration and you see that
in in this balance of linear momentum
equation
i have both the surface integration as
well as the volume integration
first of all uh
i'll have to use this surface
integration thing as well as this volume
integration formula
okay both these both these ideas will be
necessary
when applying this thing now uh
this integration tds
it will be uh it can be done
by parts over
these various surfaces so these various
surfaces mean
i have the surface abc first of all this
abc surface
then i have the surface ocb then i have
the surface oac
and then i have the surface oab so
i'm going to separate out or decompose
this entire
integration over the surface uh
into into separate parts over these
various
uh triangles okay uh
now for that
what i will actually need is the value
of
this area okay the area of this
of each of those triangles so
the way that that will keep the
derivation very neat and clean
will be to consider this triangle
abc and then to
write the the expressions for the areas
of the other triangles the triangle ocb
the triangle osc and the triangle of b
in terms
of the the area of the triangle abc
and that's a very neat idea and we can
do that again by taking
advantage of the special tetrahedron
figure because you see
the triangle ocb here is nothing but
the projection of the of the triangle
abc on this x2 x3 plane
similarly the triangle oac is nothing
but
the projection of the triangle abc on
the
x1 x3 plane and the triangle oab is
nothing but the projection
of the triangle abc
on the x1 x2 plane so we are going to
exploit
this projection idea to write down
the the the values of the various
uh triangles in terms of the triangle
abc
that is the first thing we are going to
do so
at the at the very beginning you note
that this n hat okay this n hat is the
unit outward normal to the triangle abc
now this n hat
is a generic uh unit outward normal
vector
but in terms of components how can it be
expressed
so suppose it has the components n1
n2 and n3 along each of ox1
ox2 and ox3 then can i not write it
like n 1 e 1 hat
plus n 2 e 2 hat
plus n 3 e 3 hat
can i not write like this i can of
course because i know already
that along with x1 my unit vector is e1
along with
x2 my unit vector is e2 and along with
my unit vector this e3
so n1 is the taylor component
of n hat along e 1 n 2 is the scalar
component of n hat
along e 2 and n 3 is the scalar
component of n
vector n hat along e 3. now
i'm going to use this this this
decomposition
to write down the projections of the
various
or the or the areas of the various
triangles in terms of projections so
it's like it's like this triangle ocb
that will be equal to triangle
abc times
n1 triangle
oh ac
will be equal to triangle abc
times n 2 and triangle
o a b will be equal to triangle
abc times
n3
okay if you are a little bit confused
about how this came about
you can simply take a not a tetrahedron
but a simple right angle triangle and
try to
consider the the sides of
uh of uh of the non-hypotenuse sides
of the right angle triangle of the two
legs of the right angle triangle
in terms of the projections of the
hypotenuse
okay so that way you'll get some
connection between how this is arising
and that two-dimensional figure so we'll
proceed
with the application of the balance of
linear momentum equation so we take
one look again here so i i want to write
down this
tds thing as well as i want to write
down this thing
now uh for the right hand side
okay i will write down the right hand
side first let me do that
so first of all uh i considered the
triangle abc
itself so for the triangle abc
the integration eds
what will that contribute so
[Music]
uh let's say that
this is some t vector but now
it has to be evaluated at some specific
point
x star okay it has to be evaluated at
some specific point x turn
within the triangle abc
and then i have to multiply this by
the area of the triangle let me take a
quick look
at this thing you see any integration
so this is this fr is like this e here
and then this dss the ds
so here the integrand evaluated at some
specific point within the domain
multiplied by the size of the domain and
that is exactly what i have written
here considering the triangle abc the
integration is for
the t vector with the the subscript n
and that i will have to write here i
must write this here
so this is t subscript n
the superscript star denotes that this
traction vector is now for a very
specific
point within this domain abc
okay next considering the triangle
ocb for ocb
which is my traction vector the minus t1
so
minus t vector
subscript one okay
uh so let me write this in a better
fashion
a very very nice explicit fashion
because i want to
uh write my surface integration
i put the plus and then i will recognize
that the traction vector itself is the
minus t vector
so this is minus t vector
subscript one this entire thing
and then this is multiplied with the
triangle
o c b however
this is not yet complete because i am
writing like this
by using the mean value theorem of
integration and for that i must put a
star here
this is some genes for some specific
point within the triangle ocb
now uh some of you might be thinking
i have written a star here i have
written a star here also
certainly they are not the same specific
points because you see
this this star corresponds to some point
some specific point within the triangle
abc and this start
corresponds to some specific point
within the triangle ocb
but i don't want to keep on writing
different different
stars on the superscripts i will run out
of symbols and will be a
complete mess of your writing so i hope
you all understand that this star
represents some specific point within
triangle abc this star represents
another specific point within the
triangle ocb
okay i'm not writing different different
stars for this
okay next for the triangle
o a c
it will be minus t but with the
subscript
again some specific point within the
triangle oac
multiplied by the triangle oac
and finally
for the triangle oab it should be
minus the vector
subscript 3 superscript star
or some specific point within the
triangle oab multiplied by
triangle oab
so the right hand side of this equation
sorry the right hand side of this
equation
this is done now we are going to write
the
left hand side
the left hand side so this is
rho dv
dt
b vector
this entire thing uh
multiplied by the volume of the
tetrahedron
now we don't have to fear
because again we can exploit the nice
figure that we have chosen this is the
big advantage
of this another big advantage of
considering the tetrahedron
that we can write the the entire volume
of the tetrahedron oabc
as the height of the tetrahedron
times the area of the triangle abc
okay so i repeat the volume of the total
tetrahedron
oabc is equal to
the height of the tetrahedron
so it is basically the perpendicular
distance
from the point o to the
plane abc multiplied by
the the triangle abc together
with the with the factor one third okay
so
this is one third the appropriate height
from o measured to the the plane
abc and multiplied by the triangle
the area of the triangle abc
so the most difficult part of
our derivation is actually done and let
us not forget that this
entire thing the row dv dt minus b
that is actually evaluated at some
specific point so i'm just putting a
superscript
over the entire thing okay so you
understand that
that is this star refers to some
specific point
lying within the entire domain of the
volume oabc
of the entire uh tetrahedron okay so
this is the most difficult step which we
have just done
from now it is quite easy what we'll do
now
is we can keep on proceeding like this
but now we'll do one last trick
that last trick is to consider that
our tetrahedron although we have drawn
it to be like a finite size thing to
make it look very clear
but in reality what we really need is an
is a tetrahedron which is
actually infinite simulin size i repeat
what we really need is a tetrahedron
which is infinite symbol in size because
when we consider such a tetrahedron
basically what is going to happen is
that these different different specific
points that we have seen
they are going to converge to one single
point which is nothing but this point o
this is the trick okay this is a very
very nice trick
so again i'm saying when we take
this tetrahedron to be very very small
so
that you can make by taking this height
to be very very small you keep on
reducing the height
the triangle abs abc is going to proceed
towards the origin
okay so it is going to go into the
towards the origin like that
and so
take h okay
so the triangle abc it proceeds or
starts moving towards the origin o
correspondingly the triangles ocb the
triangle oac and the triangle oab they
also become smaller and smaller so that
in the limit that at h actually tends to
zero
what will happen is that these various
specific points
okay which are actually different
different points lying in the different
different domains
the surface domains the volume domains
all these things when the
h is tending to zero what will happen is
that for all intents and purposes
that star point is nothing but the point
o itself
this is this is the i mean we don't have
to write in is
any any equation for this this
mathematical idea
but this is the most sophisticated idea
in this entire
derivation okay so once this this is
done
uh what we can do is uh
once we take this h tending to zero we
can immediately write
that the left hand side will be tending
to zero
because you understand that uh we have
the
triangle abc here and each of these ocbs
oac and oab they can be written in terms
of
these things which we can actually write
so let me write this down here okay
so this thing
is nothing but triangle abc
times uh n1
this triangle oac is nothing but
triangle
abc times n2
and this triangle oab
is nothing but triangle abc times n3 so
you see both on the left hand side on
the right hand side you have the
triangle abc
common so triangle abc can be cancelled
out from both the left hand side and the
right hand side
what remains is this h and you are
taking h tends to zero
so should we not have h on the left as
zero on the left hand side we must have
that
and what we are left with is this
we don't have to write this we don't
have to keep on writing this star
because we understand that all of these
things are evaluated
at the basically at the point zero
so this is just the tn hat evaluated at
the point
o minus
p vector 1 again evaluated at the point
o for all practical purposes
times n 1 minus
p vector
subscript 2 evaluated at the point
o times n2
finally minus t3
n3
let me write this down this important
point that in the limit
h tends to zero
all the traction vectors
are evaluated effectively
at point o
therefore what we have
is
this thing
our job is almost done okay we just have
to write
uh one another step uh
so this equation i'm going to repeat in
the next
slide and then with one more step uh
you will see that what the connection is
between the traction and the stress
all right so let me quickly finish this
up
so what i have written earlier is
en vector is p1
vector n1 plus
p2 vector n2
and t3 vector n3
you see this is a vector equation okay
since it's a vector equation
it must have within it embedded three
separate equations what are those
separate equations
so first one will be en
the first component
p1 the first component
n1 t2
the first component into
plus t the first component
n3 you please note that i'm no longer
writing the vectors
okay this this is the this equation that
i have just written
is just the first component of
this entire vector equation that i have
written earlier
similarly for the second component
i will have tn 2 is equal to
t1 to n1
plus t2 to
n2 plus t
2 and 3 and finally tn
3 the third component of that first
equation
will be t 1 3 and 1 plus
t 2 t
n 2 plus t 3
three and three now
okay the final final statement okay
final step is done
final statement final statement is this
as simple as this
that these various components these
various scalar components that you are
seeing here t
within bracket 1 1 t2 1 t3 1
e2 2 t3 to all these things all these
various
things involving the t they are
themselves nothing but the stress
components as simple as that
let me repeat these various things that
you are seeing the various terms the t
subscript 2 1 t subscript 1 to all these
things that you are seeing
they themselves are referred to as the
stress components
okay so all these things
these equations they can be rewritten
like this
sigma 1 1 n 1
plus sigma 2 1 into
plus sigma t 1
and 3 d
n 2 is equal to sigma
1 2 n 1 plus sigma
2 2 into plus sigma
t 2 and 3
e and b is equal to sigma
1 3 n 1 plus sigma 2
3 n 2 plus sigma
p 3 and 3 okay
and all of these things together
can be written in short
using initial notation or index notation
as sigma
j i n j you can check for yourself
by substituting the various values of i
and j
first of all you note that on the left
hand side
this n is just a uh just a
representation of the fact
that you are considering the traction
vector on
a plane which is the unit outward normal
is n so this
n itself is not the index it is the i
which is the index
okay the i is the index representing the
factorial nature of this
entity so uh
so you have the free index i here
meaning that this is a vector
a tensor of order one and on the right
hand side also
the entire entity whatever is written
you see the j
index is repeated so it is not a free
index it's a dummy index
the free index that you have is i and so
in in terms of the consistency of the
tensor orders also
the right hand side is very much
consistent with the left hand side
and the right hand side whatever it is
it is a tensor of order one
having only one free index and therefore
this also is a
vector quantity but expressed in terms
if you just look at look at this one the
sigma ji
that is the stress tensor okay
so uh usually what is written is that
this t the in again we don't keep on
writing this n
we just write it like e i is equal to
sigma
j i
n j this perhaps is the most
important equation that you can come
across in
uh one of the most important equations
you can come across
in all of continuum mechanics the
traction vector
is expressed in terms of the stress
components like this
so the thus the sigma
okay the in compact notation it is
written like this
the sigma equivalent to in the index
notation
as sigma ij or sigma gi
[Music]
and we will we will later on discuss
about
the fact that sigma i j is indeed equal
to sigma j i
but generally it is sigma i j or if you
want to write it like sigma p q no
problem in index notation so this
is a second order tensor
and this is the this is nothing but the
stress tensor
and this is how the connection between
the traction
and the state of stress represented by
this second order tensor
is established through the unit vector
n okay so that original notion that the
traction vector
is inherently connected to a particular
plane under consideration
characterized by the unit outward normal
to it is very much
present in this equation also all right
so
uh we will proceed from this thing
uh in the in the next part of the
lecture
but uh i again want to emphasize that
this is perhaps one of the most
important equations you will come across
in this course thank you very much